maybe I was not thought of or looked at
or allowed to be looked at I've known
darkness in my life but that was the
darkest period ever when my daughter was
Ill you just want to be the best father
and possible you want to be available to
your kids you want to be
there for them at any stage of the game
[Music]
I mean for me it's the gift you know
they're giving me the gift because to go
into a place
where you know I mean I've spent time in
Great Ormond Street I'd always kind of
done these visits but after that the
visits became more and more important
because the kids bless them you know
they're so strong they're so courageous
but the parents are the ones who are
slowly dying
and to be able to bring a smile or a
giggle
to these people is uh it means
everything in the world to me you know
it's a very strange funny time where
everybody
would love to be able to be themselves
but they can't
because they must fall in line
with the person in front of them
you want to live that kind of life I
wish you the best I'll be on the other
side somewhere you know
people can hit the bottom many times and
you can drop straight to the bottom
billion times but if you're lucky enough
to find the basement
you're all right you know by the way
I've had about 17 comebacks apparently
I keep wondering about the word comeback
because I didn't go anywhere
I don't feel boycotted by Hollywood
because I don't think about it
there were a lot of things going on but
man
you know running between all of those
raindrops
you learn
so much
so much and so much to the degree where
even the ideals better you know on
bitterness or hatred or anything
you know it's like asking a question how
are you doing
but what's underneath
in the subtext is God I hate you I
suggest that before people start
pointing fingers and making judgment on
others that they have no idea
about it I would say everybody take one
day off of work stay home start your
investigation of everyone in your family
start with your father
look way back
dad always been a wonderful guy has he
your uncles look at your brothers
look around you first before you start
passing judgment on someone that you
have no idea
what that person has been through who
they are
we're all made of Stardust
and there's truth to that if something
if that came to you every day that
thought
what a wonderful fall if we could
celebrate
every breath
that we take
because nothing's a guarantee if we
could celebrate the breath
in the exhale
which is
being alive
there are things that are very very
important in life that we we don't think
about you know and one of the most
worrisome things that I I went through
for years is you've freaked out about
your past you're worried you're scared
to death of the future and that's all
you're thinking about but the now
doesn't exist and I think that's a grave
mistake that they might I believe what
that comes down for me how I interpret
it is I knew at a certain point I needed
to accept
that everything that happened had
happened to me in my life every
experience
bad good with it
difficult emotional I knew that that
needed to be accepted
[Music]
to incorporate it into my life because
otherwise I would be in the mug house to
keep one foot in that Circle
express your truth
just
all on board it's everything
why do we have to skirt around Lives why
do we have to figure out for at an early
age because you observe people to the
degree that it's like ill
um and you see the LIE coming around the
corner
I I can't and no one should accept
anything but the truth it's easy to say
I love you
but
if it's not behind the eyes if it's not
you know there
if it's not your truth that you've
applied from
whatever you got until it's and the
audience will see it we're in a place in
this
World in my opinion there
we've gone
to the very thing that we've always been
fascinated with
which is some degree of voyeurism
because we're in the 21st century the
world's come a long ways and and it's
also regressed in a lot of ways Chinese
voyeurism in terms of
that illness to want to know what your
neighbors doing in the it feels as if
the illness of that
is a very very
important and twisted part of our
reality and kids
who need to speak and express themselves
without judgment without any kind of uh
to be
scolded for a thought we've gone into
this place where where everything's a
show and it's become this kind of
three-ring circus of the most negative
or the most absurd or the most
we're ill
when there's a monolith this Goliath in
front of you this massive
enemy and it all seems too much or it
seems to
impossible you know
Damien taught me something from the
itching and it's a symbol and it's
called the power of the small it takes
nothing but
one person to start chipping away
for all of us
to just know that chip away at the at
the tiny bits people will help keep
chipping with the small the power of the
small
works and I know that because I'm very
very small right now in front of you
before you
the best advice that I could give is
observe everything
quiet is better than loud
Simplicity is a great luxury it doesn't
last long
hang on to it
because all the simplicities that you
build become incredibly complex
ultimately I would say capture what you
want stick to your guns do what you
believe because what's the point of
copying so or being someone else or
approaching in exactly the same way that
everyone else does there's no point
if you're looking to try something and
even if you don't know what it is I'll
stick to it keep chipping away sometimes
you to wait for people to catch up with
some of the things that you created and
brought to brought to life I limited
myself I don't think I'll ever call
myself an artist I don't believe that's
my place
I can certainly and I do approach my
work my music my whatever
as an artist but that's when you're
commencing on a blank page even if
you're an artist at that moment you're
an aspiring artist because you don't
know what comes next and I've never had
any aspirations of becoming an actor
until I realized I was on that road and
there was no turning back
I would hate to limit myself as me as a
human to say yeah I'm an actor and
that's it or or what those horrible
things they call you like celebrity I
never decided to be a celebrity I never
signed a piece of paper that says sure
I'll be a public figure I would never
complain about the fact that I've been
so lucky and so fortunate to have been
able to stick around in this industry
and do the things that I love doing I
love the process of making films I'm
proud of the films that I've done
because of the people that I've worked
with you start to realize
things that you allowed yourself in life
and things that you
thought it best to let go of or walk
away from in life and sometimes those
things are very
dear to the point of it's truly a part
of you